hey this is really we're going to talk
in the next segment more about matt
gates
um donald trump had to be talked out of
publicly defending matt gates now it's
not stopping matt gates from claiming he
has trump support
and we're going to get to that later in
the show but there's a very interesting
report from
cnn and business insider and a number of
different media outlets
that donald trump had to be talked out
of publicly defending
republican florida congressman matt
gates
as reports surfaced almost daily
something new
and very bad for matt gates including
questions about whether matt gates had a
sexual relationship with a minor
whether he actually trafficked that
minor across state lines would
which would be very very bad and maggie
haberman from the new york times
reported on cnn that donald trump wanted
to come out in defense of matt gates
but presumably many of the people around
donald trump were saying
don't say a word these allegations are
really serious
haberman said quote his first impulse
was he wanted to defend gates
you know he's one of our people several
of his advisers told him it's a very bad
idea
the nature of what gates is being
investigated for is so serious that this
is not something that former president
trump
should be out on a limb for and then
we've seen the silence
from trump world and we now understand
why now again
matt gates is still saying i have trump
support i've heard from trump and it's
all going great
it's not clear whether that's true but
we're going to talk about that
after the break um the
there are some within donald trump's
circle
who actually celebrated the controversy
uh reportedly there are some people
around trump who really don't like matt
gates
and were allegedly gleeful that matt
gates was having them
this problem um a business insider
writes that another trump confidant
echoed the ass
sorry echoed the assessment um telling
politico the reason you haven't seen
people in maga
defending gates is less about him being
unpopular which he is in a lot of
circles
but more about the fact that he hasn't
done a single thing to make people
comfortable to defend him and case in
point
every time gates publicly speaks about
this
scandal it actually raises new questions
gates seems to propose or introduce
new potentially derogatory information
about himself
every single time that he does something
publicly he spoke over the weekend at a
very strange event i'll have clips after
the break for you
it raises more questions about gates who
seems to be now making himself a martyr
for allegedly having paid a minor for
sex
very very strange when he did the tucker
carlson interview
not last week but the week before he
sort of strangely
seemed to implicate tucker and even
raised new questions denying that he
ever paid for sex which at the time was
not even part of the publicly known
investigation just
it gets worse every time time after time
after time so
uh for now you know uh one one of the
really funny things
is in some way doesn't this invalidate
the q anon
conspiracy because q anon is a
conspiracy theory based on the idea
that donald trump was sent to fight an
imaginary
child sex trafficking ring run run by
democrats
if trump was eager to defend gates
despite
child sex trafficking claims it doesn't
really
sound like the type of guy who would be
fighting against
child sex trafficking that q anon
believes him to be
just a side note about yet another one
of these conflicts between these various
conspiracy theories
but despite trump not publicly
supporting matt gates
matt gates is saying that he still has
donald trump's support so we're going to
talk about that after the break
make sure that you are following me on
instagram
you can find me on instagram at
david.pacman
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
watches and i would love for you to
support these guys
and right now for a very limited time
during their spring
upgrade sale you will save up to 30
off all of their products vincero only
creates watches that are
exceptionally crafted with a sleek
modern look
and they're sustainably made which i
love i just picked up
vincero's chrono s model in gunmetal
and walnut i love the simple design
the high quality engraving on the face
with the contrast of the dark leather
strap vincero
really does create what i think are
visually beautiful watches
it's springtime it's time to upgrade
your look
freshen up your style and a great
quality watch
like this is the perfect way to do it
they also have sunglasses wallets and
bracelets
which are excellent and for a very
limited time vincero's
spring upgrade sale is giving you up to
30
off all of their products just go to
vincerocollective.com
david the link is right underneath this
video